sorry was it bad how did I rip one and
[ __ ] knowing a dreamers have to come
over hit buttons
I like being helped Jim is sitting in
the in the console chair today because I
was late coming in because I was in
Pittsburgh last night but Jim doesn't
he's not a master of the buttons just
yet he's getting there yeah what is that
it's just you know you guys know what to
hit and what not to hit and that's it
but that means adrian has to come over
and help him with some of the buttons
did you hear my fart i've heard it but I
didn't have to go over and live in it
die need you get me before yeah I
thought the wind does it was bad yeah it
was bad Dan he walks back in here I
don't know anybody who has said yeah
it's good he left yet another one you
left to get a fork and knife and a plate
because he's got to cut his omelet no I
cut already well then what'd you get a
fork in I didn't know was cut oh I see
oh but you didn't you thought it was
uncut and then you found out it was cut
didn't you were happy
mmm what it's uncut or cut the last time
you cried because Danny is not emotion
emotionally in touch with himself but I
but I'm surprised because you know we
tease Danny but he's a pretty
emotionally sturdy guy right except for
the I mean that I only know one thing
that bothers him yeah boys that this
self sock stuff he hated we don't talk
about that anymore no we don't you
really wept yeah I really I don't know
could you recall the list you said it's
quite recently though but Dan you're a
guy like Anthony Anthony will say like
Anthony said weird [ __ ] like you're like
yeah yeah I'll be there but then he
doesn't come but then he'll do things
like he said the last time he cried was
when his dad died and I'm amazed that
the guy's gone to 20 years without
crying like you know I mean like just
able to wall things off and not get you
know affected by them yeah I've gotten
uh I really I was that when I was
watching that movie room would brie
Larson I had a couple of good cries
throughout that movie and I don't cry
during movement what a queer why no I'd
never cry Jerry movie the jealousy wish
you could be locked in a room with a kid
right no I liked with the guy who owned
the room was doing to her every night
it's like lucky girl
but um ya know I normally don't cry
during movies I cried during like the
happy parts of that movie and I've never
what a crummy party to cry when William
H Macy wouldn't talk to her that's not a
happy part Oh
when uh when I like when the kid gets a
dog right when the kid is escaped and he
gets a dog I was a dog I started crying
I didn't couldn't control myself
why what kind of dog did he get I don't
know he just really wanted a dog cause
he didn't know they were real cuz he
read it in a book oh he thought they
were fake yeah and then cuz he didn't
know anything outside he heard it didn't
he hurt it with a rock nice and men it's
a different room altogether oh you know
what made me uh I'll tell you what made
me cry maybe two it's probably good
probably about two years ago now it was
a BuzzFeed post oh and I know exactly
what you're gonna say dog yep
yeah did this get you too it got me
close I didn't see the dog she just left
hey Chris [ __ ] off I was like I was
sobbing like eyes like crying a real cry
I really see the post hold on can we do
this yeah can you somehow tell Adrienne
the post and I could see it and see if
it affects me at all yeah you don't fake
it I won't fake it I D honest I just
look it up and you talk to Danny okay so
Denny what kind of wood are you eating
on your omelet I'm eating it egg white I
mean looks like turkey and avocado now
what would you like for Christmas what
do you want for this what do you want
for this color I'd like world peace for
Christmas that's kind of a tough
question I mean I'm happy you know in my
life I have a good career I have good
friends have a good family life I'm here
to be part of the Jim and Sam show what
else do I need
okay now we're gonna watch this post to
do with this video this is a pose okay
it's a post it's not a video I can't
even like watch it you have to yeah we
have to watch it together I'm not a
video are you are you a dog person yeah
who isn't behavior I mean did you grow
up with dogs no but I the cats I love
animals I love my only active bravery
and my life was saving a cat lemon let
me see this is a dog I died today bye
Roberts oh good I wish that they spelled
Sam wrong almost made me so hopeful it's
a picture of a dog and it looks like
he's only got a stupid leg got three
legs
oh great but you see he's got the the
plate full of hamburgers and
cheeseburgers in front of him with
exactly pie stole them and they cut his
leg off he's part of a cartel you're
gonna read this already like that photo
is making me really upset because it's
obvious that they know they're gonna put
him to sleep
so they're giving him all these
cheeseburgers so we can have a great
last day cool let me say go bang a dog
just and I ate a lot of hamburgers we
had a party and I laughed all right he's
got three legs this lady's standing
there he's so loved nice shiny coat of
course he is and I thought about how
much I'm gonna miss it here here do you
read it stand the next one uh-huh
it says we told jokes and all the
families around him
I choked as a dog like two cats walk
into a bar you know what happened you
have a Polish cat a black cat a white
cat what happened all three cats were
killed the dogs laughing hey you want to
hear a joke two Jews walk into a bar
what happened they sniffed each other's
crotches material dog material oh my god
I feel like I died and went to peanut
butter [ __ ] in here can you turn that
down I mean sexually when you walked in
okay okay so okay we told jokes can we
go back to down a little bit more it's
as we told jokes he told ya more yeah we
were serious that's it yeah there's Dan
he's already gonna read it for me I'm
sorry that's okay you eat we would
because we were serious and the dog is
just kind of looking XM it's a picture
of its the serious job dog was like you
can't be serious okay we were cm now
what and then it says it says my friend
from next door came to see me they're
twins
when someone offered them one of my
hamburgers one said no thank you I don't
want to take any from Dookie no that's
terrible and the two kids
on top of each other they don't wanna
take any from Dukey I stepped in Dukey
once I hated it
go ahead some of them were easy ones
Kristen came to see me she's a hoot
she's my groomer and my buddy my groomer
she helps him get children Oh No she's
not having the same effect on you as a
no I love dogs
exactly nobody's burgers aren't you make
the window smaller so we can don't get
lost rolling it three legged burden yeah
I have a burger or what else while we
were waiting for the vet to uh while we
were waiting for the vet to come they
want some guy from Vietnam to blow just
masturbate exactly what is no leg hold
on I lost my two legs but I still got my
third yeah she'll got my one leg she's
smelling hamburgers what we were waiting
for the vet to come Kristen said we were
going for a walk then someone said how
about a play in the water at the splash
park down the street so off we went okay
so there's a picture of them and I'm
taking them to like have like a fun day
sure you know and then it's a photo of
the of the girl and the dog and they're
talking to each other and the quote says
you know I'm going to miss you right
yeah and the dog looks all happy and you
too right oh and the dog is looking at
the camera when he says and you too
right yes and then he says I need you to
help me watch over my family did you
hear me this is all I want and now the
dogs like you know yelling it's kind of
being cute or whatever so we got wet
today and then the the groomer and the
family's there and they're at the water
park and the dog is just loving yeah
just dragging this one-legged hunk of
[ __ ] under the rainbow three-legged
wherever it is it says we smile today
and the dogs having a really good day
yeah good we felt grateful today I don't
know if dogs can feel great if they
can't we broke the rules today it does
look in her [ __ ]
okay it says I listen to the kids play
off in the distance
yay hugs you pecker I bet and thought
about my two babies at home I loved
protecting them it's in past tense yeah
I can't like why they're in the park
what happened it says I relax today
that's nice to relax what is she doing
she's putting the drugs in the needle
that you inject into a dog so first it
goes to sleep and then you can put the
other drugs in it to stop its heart oh
maybe just has an allergy yeah because I
get allergy shots like that I wish you'd
get allergy shots like that okay so what
happened they put to sleep let's go the
next one there's a picture of the lady I
I felt no pain even though the tumor
grew so big it's like Dennis being on
this show and the dog is just falling
asleep I felt loved today oh I said
goodbye to my beautiful friend Kira my
like here's the one writing that so she
had to put in that little [ __ ] thing
for herself yeah I said goodbye to my
big titted hot friend she saw me
standing over everybody before the
doctor said it was time I was excited
and jumping and happy oh and she's
giving the dog a kiss well I didn't say
goodbye I said till we meet again god I
uh god I was lucky our time was our time
was short but you both gave me a second
chance it's getting you Adrienne isn't
it crazy that it gets you even with even
with [ __ ] Norton's like yeah yeah
it's still like I know because everybody
likes [ __ ] dogs you can say that
again
says but you both gave me a second
chance and we lived it up together you
love when I look at you and I'll never
stop now you didn't read you read
they're too fast I read it fine no you
didn't
summer go back a little bit Jesus says
but even you ready you ran through it
like that could even hear you I'm busy
Dennis by the way has the same [ __ ]
goofy 70s lock jock smile on his face
just remains unaffected it says god I
was lucky our time was short but you
both gave me a second chance and we
lived it up together you you love when I
look at you I'll never stop thank you
Sam that's not what I'm saying to you it
was nice
always Dukey and there's his paw I hate
that boy you hate his paw because you
know there's not one on the other side
denied you've never put a dog to sleep
sure I have talked to it [ __ ] nut oh
this is adoption video they got Dukey
adopted three years ago they can only
make him last three years well it's an
old dog owners oh you are you looking at
Dukey let's grab the name f2 [ __ ] by the
way it's great
our [ __ ] our dog turd and Dukey my
cat's name is a log this is a little
much this music yeah turn it off it's
like wait see he's only got four legs
there and then he's got three they took
one of his legs off cuz he probably
[ __ ] barked they beat him with his
own leg but no no because he had the
tumor no I think it's I think Jim's
right disciplinary yeah yeah
Dukey well that's a nice you doc Dukey
you take one of his legs off you hit him
with it yeah laughs maybe they were
green day fit I made you cry after the
Dookie oh yeah no that made me cry and
then I cried it was fright I think it
was more recently when we put my last
dog to sleep well your dog I can
understand yeah yeah yeah Kara's here by
the way huh so why'd you put your dog to
sleep just getting annoying or it was
old and he couldn't see or hear any more
at all okay and so like his quality of
life was for [ __ ] it was just terrible
put it there please easier yeah yeah his
career his quality of life is no hood
and Mikey at some point that's the worst
part like at some point like that's what
I'm saying that's why I'm an advocate
for putting Travis's dog to sleep it's
because its quality of life is just
terrible absolutely should have put it
in his sleep a long time ago right over
there
how dare you yeah no I think that I
think it's a good idea I think all
Dexter's about time you get a whole
bunch of cheeseburgers I absolutely
think so too but but why even pay all
that just cheeseburgers and a [ __ ]
hammer on his head his head how old your
dog he's - hello Adrian you gotta hit
the button which one is it Jim's in the
captain's chair for the first time today
yes so he's not familiar with all the
buttons ya know it's an exciting day to
be oh thank you so much do you sing at a
soiree sighs okay what's cool you have a
new gig - I do you're in KFC radio now I
am on KFC radio and I'm work I'm a
full-time employee at barstool sports
that's amazing
my first real job ever yeah I'm 32
I've been doing yeah like sex work for
my entire adult life so I am still doing
it I only shoot four wicked pictures now
and I shoot one movie a month they
condom only wicked pictures they are
yeah there was some one of the companies
that were going condom only were you
happy about that are you like that no no
we've been condom only since like the
beginning of time and you prefer that um
you know I'm happy to be with wicked and
I'm I am totally you know happy to be
condom only I don't think it should be
mandatory like as you know for the
industry as a whole or any that's just
their policy yeah it's weird how people
get into broadcasting cuz Dennis also
before he got into radio was in sex work
but his work is only on the Deep Web
absolutely you can't find it you know in
any mainstream sources they tried to go
condom only but Dennis is like no it
bothers his rectum condoms in the rectum
are definitely something you get used to
you do right yeah see that as we do how
long does it take to get yours out of
this we just by the way before you came
in we just sure we're talking because
Dennis isn't emotionally he died in 1971
emotionally doesn't cry I'm a blubbering
idiot with movies and Sam cries dog
videos are you a crier or not like dog
like the dog
last day dogs getting put to sleep all
that stuff kills dogs kills me I will
cry any commercial with dogs I will cry
I cried the other day at a Barbie
commercial I cry a lot
my apartment commercial you saw the
black one you didn't like it right it
was one of those commercials where it
was very like you know when little girls
play with Barbies they think about their
dreams or something like that and I was
just like did you see this always that
Marley & Me yeah I've never watched a
dog movie oh you'll never catch me
watching the dieting you see Marley and
they all end the same way cuz dogs dogs
they die and so I thought about the
reggae singer the black people of humans
right right exactly put a dog in a movie
it's gonna be the lifespan of the dog
yeah yeah black people always get killed
in films first a fact okay so did you
identify such a movie buff he loves to
be sure is a good guy so we just watch
the dog video with Sam where they post
about the dog like that stuff guest you
like a dog okay it doesn't get it does
yeah yeah but I mean that one didn't but
I become being obnoxious like mother
always said that when something sad
happens I make a dumb remark but yeah
I'm a crybaby comes from a place of pain
so how did you get how did you get the
the gig at bars fula that's a huge
podcast so I wrote um I wrote a book
last year and then I went on not KFC
radio but on mail time one of their
podcasts to promote it and like I just
really got along with Kevin and I got
along with everyone at barstool and they
were basically like do you want to work
here and I had been looking you know I
used to do DVD a sa which you were on
Jim yes and you know that ended and I
really wanted to do another show or like
a podcast or something so it came along
at the perfect time and I just got
really really lucky why did it with
David show was the you could put the
heat on just a little bit's a little
chilly in her with with David you guys
did a very fun podcast it was honest it
was really good what happened to it um
you know Dave is just taking like a
different direction
with his life and you know we never made
any money with that show like we it only
cost Dave money he's got a lot of face
he has a lot of it yeah it's I don't
feel bad or anything right but if you're
on the podcast you'd like for incoming
in yeah it was basically like my social
life for two years and then so yeah so
it was it was just for fun
and then one barstool comes to you and
you're like you can make money off these
things like what what
but yeah it's cool so I'm two weeks out
of the month I'm in New York now and
barstools like such a fun environment I
think it's the perfect transition for me
like out of porn which is super fun into
a real job which didn't sound like so
much fun so you like porn like like a
lot of people have a weird thing with
performing arts terrible it's bad but
you actually you enjoy it and you you
what did you came from a background that
was not necessarily typical of someone
who gets into not at all I'm actually
from the city um a big apple oh yeah a
big a lot Eppler yes I don't let's not
be from a big a plural I'm like what
like I didn't know anybody and I didn't
even know a hooker growing up I could
have talked to you really really
fascinated by just like I I got arrested
once for shoplifting and I met a hooker
in in central booking all right I was I
must have been 18 because I was in
bookings um but I just remember thinking
like oh my god this is like the coolest
person I've ever met in my whole life I
had been waiting for someone like that
to cross paths with what did your
parents do my dad's a photographer my
mom runs a not-for-profit organization
so they're very like not important at
all obvious and what question was what
were you stealing it was a bottle of
Ralph Lauren true romance oh man that
was the perfume like and from I don't
even want to say where cuz I go there
all the time
okay so your parents were like no kind
of free spirits though
but your parents are still exactly what
you would you let your educated you went
to college
private school so I went to Manhattan
private school the United Nations school
so I feel like I got a head start in
that way I did not go to college I went
straight into being a dominatrix like
inaudible yeah will you hold you lost
your virginity 13 Wow oh wow that's
young okay it's not though not four not
four in New York really was the guy in
Jersey that's young the guy was like one
year older than the guy you do you liked
and like you so the dominatrix fourth
did you like being dominate or that was
just kind of where the market was I'm I
think I'm not really pretty submissive
sexually but it was such a new world and
like I was learning stuff every day and
it's such it's like such a power trip I
think and it was the first time I had
ever like put on a strap-on or you know
just like felt that kind of power so it
was really really eye-opening so is that
the the dominatrix thing what made you
Nate I'm gonna do that sexually like of
all the head you ever done your personal
I know I had never done it I had at that
point I had never done anything in the
sex world I think I replied to an ad on
Craigslist once in high school to be a
hooker and like I chickened out but now
these were the kinds of dreams and
aspirations I had so you're playing with
your Barbies and win it when you did
have dreams that was hooker Barbie
dominatrix Barbie Bobby squatting over
Ken I was just walking down the street
one day and this like dude came up to me
and he was like are you interested in
being in the adult entertainment
industry and like for me it was it was
as if like you were an angel like wow I
was like oh my god I've been waiting for
you my whole life
yes I do want to be entertainment
industry and me upstairs because that
guy like like he does that to people and
usually you have to convince girls yeah
there was no convincing no like yes I've
been waiting for that question you'll
probably still his only recruit before
and after you're beautiful and I can go
to a beautiful woman she is
to do that and he was so shady looking
like he was missing his front teeth he
had a pony to help oh no I mean he was
totally shady looking and I followed him
upstairs to a dungeon and I began
training the next day that's the other
thing that's the other tough so it's
like do you want to be in the adult
industry yes will you follow me upstairs
yeah yes yeah it was I mean I was with
my ex at the time so I mean I I felt
sort of saying oh you're walking with a
guy NES you this yeah Wow pretty bro
what's the worst part is like at that
time I was addicted to oxycontin
so I was not only was I just walking
down the street I had just thrown up
because like I used to just barf all the
time like sick baby used to do that too
no he's a premature baby he can't help
it he doesn't like doing hard work no
yes it he gets nervous and he throws up
on himself he does that he does that and
I got in trouble at the Christmas party
yeah well yeah so a you see your first
time to dominating somebody what
happened you go there how long do you
train for a day and it was on the guy
that recruited me Oh
looking back I mean I'm so glad I did
that that happened back then because now
if it were to happen I'd be like hell no
get away from me or I'm calling the
police
right how do you train for that cuz you
need to have like a certain confidence
right that you're gonna be able to
dominate yeah this man and if it doesn't
come naturally to you you could mean
back then a lot of that confidence came
just from being high right I forgot your
uh Nazis yeah so there was that my
husband a he was with you in the room
when you did this um
the training no okay but he was very
open like we were in an open
relationship
he married oh he was thirty when I was
19 so he he had quite a bit of
experience on him he was obviously not a
conventional gosh so yeah so the
training was like I think on my first
day I I sounded him which is like I yeah
you open a [ __ ] hole yeah
wait way we've never done it but what is
plain what sounding is yeah I don't know
basically there's like an imagine of
modding is not a guy that movie with
paul winfield like this cord this
microphone oh my god that's really thick
and then i mean they come in all
different sizes but and you insert it
into a man's urethra and it's crazy cuz
like you put the tip in and then it just
kind of like sucks the rest of it up a
little bit I don't I mean yeah I'm sure
I did but and then there's ones that can
like electrocute you but that's like
that's where you started yeah I believe
like I did that on my first day right
into the deep end yeah it's like ooh I'm
gonna whip not a lot of spanking or like
they call it corporal punishment like
very little of that more like
humiliation when you got a steel rod
down in your [ __ ] pee hole spanking
seems a little bit like child's play but
you know what everyone it made me really
really it opened my eyes and like made
me way less judgmental because like
everyone's into something weird is what
I realized there so when you where you
go you start sounding which I've never
been done I'm a dirty guy and I've never
even come close to that you should do it
no it doesn't appeal to me I don't think
it's necessarily like levels right it's
like I'm sure you do stuff that's like
way crazy on a differential power so you
doing sounding with this guy the first
day and your first client we're all
sounding by the way I don't know how did
you scream so you do this the first day
was your first client the first time you
show up what was your Dom name um
Sookie is hey Mike I went by but I
didn't choose that name it was given to
me okay um the first client I ever had
was he wanted to just do a roleplay
where basically he we would we were
sitting on the subway and he kept
looking at me and then I was telling him
to stop looking at me and then I I
basically just like shamed him for for
being a creep and was he checking off he
jerked off yeah why
what did you say - how do you shame
somebody for jerking off you insulting
them physically like a decade yeah yeah
yeah I guess I was like you're
disgusting like you're a piece of [ __ ] I
mean I don't even have it in me anymore
yeah at the time I really really loved
it but he loves ya so here's why I'm
asking that because I talked to a girl
recently and she's uh she was talking
about dominating somebody in an escort
scenario and she told me that this guy
wanted to be humiliated and dressed like
a girl and humiliated but and talked
down to and she's she's transgender
so she he wanted to be dressed and she
said that he said could say anything you
want just don't call me cuz he was obese
you don't call me fat I know I'm fat
like that was his thing that's my thing
why I have so much in common with this
guy um I I love being called like a
[ __ ] and a [ __ ] and just like I like to
be a little bit degraded maybe not so
much humiliated but I like being degree
sure but as soon as someone calls me fat
I'm like boy you faster you're not fat
not fat I mean since I call you Irish
yeah but I'm a girl right sure so like I
mean we all have those insecurities and
stuff but it's interesting were like you
know someone draws the line that's crazy
from you they're like from a guy who's
fat cuz you're beautiful like a guy
who's fat I could go that that's your
Achilles right but for you I could see
like you saying I had I want an ethnic
slur I don't want this in that bag I say
that to you that wouldn't occur to me in
bed to say to somebody so you're da man
all these people what your limits did
you have any limits because everyone I
wouldn't do any like Scott play sure you
wouldn't shed on it um yeah did you get
requests for it yeah oh yeah definitely
it would pee on guys and I would [ __ ]
them in their ass but I would absolutely
not do anything to do with [ __ ] I
wouldn't even like be in the room if
another girl was [ __ ] so we used the
first strap-on thing you ever did how
did that work I put on a strap-on no I
mean like the scenario do you say no but
I mean like did he say I want you to do
this or did you say [ __ ] it I want to do
this or did you have to be talked into
it I knew going into it that he was
someone who liked that and he chose me
and they were like are you comfortable
doing that and I was like I don't know
cuz at that time I had never even been
[ __ ] in the ass myself
so um I but I was like okay I want to
try it I mean it sounds like a lot of
fun and then I did but I I feel bad for
the guy now because now having done so
much anal I think I'm so much better at
giving it and they're like there's just
practice like you know I don't want I
mean I don't I wouldn't want a girl
[ __ ] my ass with a strap-on unless
she had done anal because it's such a
especially because with a strap-on like
you can't feel the dick on you right so
it's it's very I don't know Dennis
you're saying removed from Dennis for
saying something similar on 70s on seven
recently as he was entering a song
that's true what song was it I'm just
taking this all in how do you feel
[Laughter]
welcome Zsa Zsa Gabor died yeah the rest
of her did she started dying years ago
yes 99 she's married support yeah for
five years five years that's Bush I
think it's very cruel yeah that is
really cool and that is some rich people
should yeah to keep someone on life
support for five years she had nine
husbands
oh my dream really are you married again
or no I'm married again this is my
second one and I would like to do it
seven more times wait are you are you
not enjoying this marriage no I'm
definitely I'm immensely enjoying this
marriage but I think the most romantic
thing in the world is when two people
get divorced and then marry each other
again Wow have you guys talked to vorse
or no no oh yeah oh yeah not yet but you
may are you the type that's gonna like
eventually create a fight out of nothing
just so you can have that conflict just
so you can come back together I mean I
am a woman yeah do you guys fight a lot
or no actually we don't this is
definitely the healthiest relationship
I've ever been in because I'm a fighter
are you for sure and I'm crazy do you
still do drugs or no no I'm sober
oh okay so what do you get crazy about
um I mean again yeah
and that rage can be a fun drug to
advantage yes I'm I'm pretty jealous
despite being in porn well what does he
do he's important to be though that to
me that makes sense because you
understand the difference between a work
dynamic and a personal relationship and
being a jealous person that's not the
greatest thing a lot of people are
important but I'm not jealous about at
all about sex like he can do whatever he
wants on set he can have sex with anyone
he wants I don't care it's like the
emotional stuff when you see him
laughing with somebody oh my god kills
me crazy right if a girl can make him
laugh I'm like get her out of our lives
really we don't want to go crack them up
Wow yeah I mean it's it's not like a
rational thing but that's really
interesting that you that it's the
emotional stuff that would yeah would be
a threat to you yeah because sex is
pretty like I don't know I mean you can
do it with people you don't love I don't
know right different and there's
something like you can't get like if
it's just sex like you could get better
and worse at sex right like it's a it's
an act like if he looks like he's
falling for somebody else
you're on sex you're out of control
you're like yeah they're amazing I can
do it right it's too late to work on my
personality this is the improved version
of him exactly but sexually you can
always change stuff yeah and not only
that like you you know you could [ __ ]
someone that you love [ __ ] today but
you don't want to like watch Netflix
with them right right right it's that
whole thing do you guys know what's the
difference between sex together and sex
when you guys are on set is it just much
more loving together or is it is it
similar sometimes um no it's definitely
similar because I met him on a porn set
oh yeah shot together yeah we shot
together I met him in my first DP scene
ever Wow so romantic
you had me
pretty much all the dicks that were
inside me I chose yours that's awesome
that's such an awesome way to meet
though so it's double penetration which
means one the vagina one in the anus yes
and um and he was in the vagina he was
in both oh you want for that I'm amazed
that men in point is there hard during
that I would panic it was my erection
those it's because you're neurotic I'm
crazy yeah but I mean my dick is very
tentative anyway my dick is like Samuel
the shy sea lion is [ __ ] backs out all
the time very unreliable it really is
the [ __ ] so you guys he's [ __ ] you
in the with another guy and their dicks
are just almost touching and they're
both functioning fine yeah Wow they're I
mean he's European so I I don't think
he's he's definitely not gay but he's
comfortable you know I mean a homoerotic
or homophobic way I just mean simply no
pressure of people watching you [ __ ] you
got to keep your dick hard while the
other guys [ __ ] it's so much well
he's been doing it for 22 years now
so I I would say he's like used to it
does he take pills yeah everyone
important they do right how about
cabbage it um
I know what I personally know there may
be like four or five guys that do that
it's for quadriplegics it's an injection
that goes in the base of your penis and
like viagra is like it'll help you right
but you have to be horny still you know
right like it helps you get hard but
calves eject is like you don't have to
be horny at all it's an insta Boehner is
eject or jet I always I imagined it to
be cover checked oh you might be good
probably right yes I could I've never
seen it in Britain form camera jack
you're correct okay which hole was your
husband in when you realized you were
falling probably the vagina oh yeah
we'll have some cabbage Jack please lady
or cheese can't you [ __ ] your dick up
with that stuff that freaks me I'll take
Cialis but the [ __ ] injections into
it yeah that's that's bad stuff I think
it becomes you become like reliant on
and I think you reach a certain point
where you can't get hard without it it's
also really dangerous because like like
I know guys who've broken their dicks on
it
you don't feel it go hard and you don't
feel it and the girl will just be riding
you so hard and it's I mean we feel pain
for a reason right right yeah
yeah so I think it's just yeah where the
blood won't go back down through it like
yeah black like a purple because the
blood they have to drain your [ __ ]
that's really freaking me up but I guess
everyone uses the pills now yeah I mean
pretty much everyone you know a lot of
people and I just wonder like from your
perspective Dennis Falcone has only had
sex with one woman did you know that
your whole life yep I actually yes yes I
mean I find that to be pretty romantic
yes is it but also aren't you so curious
no no really isn't she so curious yes no
we just met were in college okay but you
I don't think it's as bad because kind
of we rolled to a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
right now and it was just it was just
again it was a different time like we
didn't go away together on vacation
before we were married you didn't know
I'd be watching TV over her house it you
know 11 o'clock or that wasn't show no
nut back then you know and her dad would
come down and say alright getting late
isn't it okay so will you marry before
you had sex with each other or were you
like already in like a real relationship
no we had sex before were before married
denizen play games he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
slinging all over the campus yeah fine
no we're gonna go talk to me into it I
was like whoa she said right really yeah
you didn't want to know no I did she
said we're going out for a couple of
years now I said okay it was two years
what did you get hand jobs
what's it we took care of each other
yeah maybe oral oral a sloppy third
sloppy third okay
is sliding into third over sliding the
band over slide in the back for you it's
not as like I really do think at the end
of the day like I feel like [ __ ] how
can how different can different dude is
such a different experience guy to guy
is it really like most men have this
thing this conquering thing and you
don't conquer one and you're done you
know what have you conquered you want to
conquer multiple exactly exactly that's
the psychology I think behind everything
conquered it's almost like you have to
either [ __ ] only one for your whole life
right or a hundred right yeah exactly
you kind of don't want to be anything in
between right so you're only not 99 away
from that hundred right Sam how many
times I tell them it's not true he's a
hundred percent convinced that I've also
only had sex with one woman
now he's [ __ ] a couple of different
girls but not many no not madly for well
because I've been in a relationship for
12 years since there's a 20 yeah Wow
I've been in them too yeah do you have a
cheat in a relationship no never never
you've never done cheated I'm pretty
sure I've never been cheated I've never
been cheated on that I know of but I've
also been in a lot of open relationships
I don't it's been like a really long
time since I've been monogamous with
anyone but do you like not being
monogamous like for me like it's just a
guy who's like an average [ __ ] that
would freak me out but if a guy's a
great [ __ ] and he's in poor and he
probably doesn't care you don't you know
you don't want to be in a monogamous I
mean well first of all my husband and I
are monogamous outside of work but
that's because you know we do for work
yeah there's only so much time in the
day but um I don't know I it's been so
long and the last time I was monogamous
I was in high school so I don't even
know if that's like an option for me I
really like a variety like I enjoy a
variety gem you'd be afraid you get
shown up I know I would let me ask you
this I mean I mean you're definitely
gonna get shown up cuz once you're in a
relationship you're having sex for like
30 seconds in dictionary
I say seven minutes is all you need
seven minutes is almost too long sorry
that's right Ellie
guys they don't understand seven minutes
start to finish you're doing like just
straight-up vaginal missionary seven
minutes so you have you been with guys
in the business who are not more
connected to than your husband but who
are quote unquote and I say a better
[ __ ] I know that without the emotion
like look at nacho Vidal is supposedly
one of the best [ __ ] of all time or
rocco siffredi those guys get [ __ ]
better than most men so does your
husband care if you're with a guy like
that who's just known as being a machine
um I mean my husband's like a machine
I'm sure it's like why I asked for his
number in the first place but yeah he he
definitely like wants me to have a good
time when I go to work he doesn't yeah
he's never he's never the only rule he
has now for porn is that his request is
that I don't lick men's [ __ ] anymore
wow what a prude yeah nice a romantic
dirty [ __ ] and women have clean
that's a very reasonable request I would
agree with that I got caught doing it
because I'll bet you if he had said lick
all the [ __ ] you want you wouldn't
have did you just need like something
sneaky to do right hi caught well yeah
filming maybe that's what it was maybe I
don't know but I was [ __ ] the guy's
ass and like like it was I wasn't gonna
like put it in drawing so you licked it
and what how did he find out he watch
the scene what he said he would in the
trailer it was doing Silveira he's a
good friend was a strap attack one of
those it was a strap attack of course I
haven't seen a lot of those but I don't
Joey does them so yeah so I mean I
wasn't gonna put our you know what it
wasn't a strap attack and that's why
there was no Lube on set and I think we
were just playing with a dildo and I I
think it just like organically went in
that direction and that's why I used my
tongue and not and what did he say when
he saw it you I gotta talk to you it was
like a screaming fight and you know at
the time we were living in an apartment
and I'm sure our neighbors all heard
like you said you weren't gonna like
menthol anymore and you just wanted to
get away with something like I think it
was fun
I think being sneaky is fun too and
that's I think that's why I like it's
bad to put in any relationship I feel
like I try not to put
any rules on men because whatever that
is or may put a rule on that you
actually want them to break know coming
on her face
that's all they're gonna do is come on
the face yeah you're right absolutely
don't buy me jewelry yeah I hate that I
hate that don't [ __ ] a girl then buy me
jewelry because that would turn me off
then they're gonna sneak anything and
they're gonna do it so you leak the
guy's ass and how did you know you were
caught you saw in the trailer he just
yelled at you he brought his laptop to
me and he's like what is this hey did
you check the first no I think that's
right though I'm fascinated with that I
think you do even in an unconventional
relationship still have that thing where
you want to get away with something or
something feels like oh it'll be dirty
if I do this because it's not allowed or
whatever it is and it makes you want to
break the one rule I think it's human
though I don't think it's crazy it's
like I think every person has that just
because you're in porn or you're a sex
worker doesn't mean you're not gonna
have the same to push the envelope a
little bit she's gamble ups different
for you guys that's how I feel about
porn in general though like I always
think if it weren't taboo I don't know
that I'd be so obsessed and drawn to it
like I like that it's kind of bad yeah
right yeah and you do like now talk
about legalizing like you know
prostitution and all that stuff and do
you think it would be safer if they
legalized their only dangerous because
it's illegal I mean like if we legalized
prostitution you know we could ask for
things like testing protocol you know
like there wouldn't be pimps charging
girls like you know 80% of their money
or whatever I I think legalizing
prostitution would be the first thing I
did if I were president do you think
that crimes against sex workers go
unreported because they know that what
they're doing is illegal yeah definitely
I mean same with I think any illegal
profession like even drug dealers like I
think everything just should be legal no
we don't do you want them I'm undecided
because belladonna got out of porn I
think when she had a daughter she just
kind of wanted to just go in a different
direction is that why you're not sure
cuz you don't know if you want it if you
want to work in the industry with um you
know I also wonder if it's even too late
like I know a lot of people in
who have kids and they're actually like
doing a really great job raising their
kids but I but I can't help but think
about like you know I've done everything
I wanted to in my adult life would it be
so selfish to like bring a kid into this
world and like can you imagine being in
middle school and some kid coming up to
you like I just saw your mom's [ __ ]
on the Internet how many times I've
heard that you're young so saying if
you've already done everything that you
want to do in your adult life but I've
got to do something I wanna keep doing
everything I don't know like I I'm I'm
32 now so I I'm definitely like the
pressure is on I have to start really
thinking about it but I don't know I
don't know how does feminists handle you
because you're feminists always make sex
workers look like victims and in look in
some cases they are or they've been
trafficked and there's a lot of that but
you're you're not someone they can
dominate conversationally because you're
smart you know what you want to do and
you're like we're empowered yeah you
could argue that you're a feminist yeah
like I definitely consider myself a
feminist very much I mean I believe in
equal rights for men and women blah blah
blah but um I think feminists like the a
lot of the like anti-sex extremist
feminists I would say have a problem
with anyone who chooses to do porn or
says that the porn I do is degrading or
but um I think that's like a pretty
closed minded way to think because a lot
of them sexually might be big
submissives too like a lot of them might
enjoy being spit on or totally and I
think I think I feel like I definitely
agree with that theory that being
submissive or liking humiliation and
stuff like comes from a place where you
know were raised to be ashamed of our
sexuality and it's almost like a safe
way to play out our sexuality when we're
being forced to do it like yeah like I
definitely feel all of that I love like
rape play and stuff do you really
I've had a lot of girls that like that I
hope ya know I've gotten a few of those
too but I I feel weird doing it like I
like it but I you know you like you like
it I enjoy it if I know the person
really is right about it like you kids
then it feels like wow
doing something really dark oh I see
like like that person enjoys it but she
won't tell other people yeah I like you
know you know the secret that turns me
on
yeah so he's still old-fashioned deep
down yeah that's true I want to act out
a rape with somebody who they don't know
I can't be too mean either like I can be
degrading but I can't be too mean and I
don't like being mean either
like I I had an ex boyfriend who was
really into me I don't even know if I
can say this word go ahead push him um
[ __ ] oh yeah sure for me to call him
that when I was [ __ ] his ass let's
not get crazy yeah it wasn't yeah in the
grand scheme of things I guess it's not
that crazy but like that's like almost
as far as I can go like even in porn
like I won't do any of the racial stuff
especially when I'm like [ __ ] a black
guy I'm not gonna like do any of that do
they want you to do I've heard black
guys I know a lot of white girls at a
[ __ ] black guys and they they like it
they want me to call me a [ __ ] life it
was hard to do I didn't want to do it
yeah I don't
camera it feels weird right and what if
it gets taken out of your shirt yeah
you know like somebody could easily say
well didn't you make a movie where you
did this is this the type of person that
you want to Bob right and the thing is
like if that were my fantasy I would
have no problem doing it yeah but it's
not my fantasy at all it doesn't turn me
on I'm literally just doing that for a
paycheck so that's do it like politicize
sex and whether it's like feminists and
porn or whether it's racial or whatever
because just about everybody that comes
out and talks about porn being immoral
or whatever this type of porn being bad
or that type form being bad all it takes
is a little digging and you find out
what kind of weird thing that they're
into right and they become a hypocrite
maybe a lot of digging just needs to be
a whole separate different thing from
like politics though because it's not
fair to like I think like when you make
when you try to make sex like an ethical
thing like it sucks yeah yeah stop using
sex as a weapon that's what I say you
say that I've never heard you say that
but I do believe it's your philosophy
I want to ask you to you have your
interesting too because you attended the
United Nations International School on a
scholarship I was a scholarship for so
my grandfather was a diplomat oh we're
from Japan and then too I mean he was in
New York for a while that's how my
parents ended up here he was in
Australia he was in Myanmar it's been a
bunch of place do you speak Japanese I
do
can you say something Japanese whatever
you would say well whatever is
comfortable for you to say how about
this can you say say something like like
like sexual to Dennis yeah anything
sexual no way because I only speak it
with my family and it feels so great
you're saying it's a challenge I don't
even know how to say anal how about this
do you know how to say ass Sam oh
[ __ ] day childish or shitty so how
would you tell that you don't even kiss
my OCD I like I I wouldn't know just try
to respect them I mean like technically
I guess you could say oh she do you so
stick with outside but like that does
not sound sexy at all
no thank you willing to learn is it
happy yes
Sam that was very fast you've been
waiting to say that just came on your
first language so Japan they're kind of
like it's a different culture they're
very a little bit more stoic I think
yeah very stoic so how do they respond
to your thank your grandfather or not
like my parents are pretty like creative
emotional people but my grandparents
don't know my cousin's in Japan found
out that I'm doing porn and I mean it
was kind of stressful and straining on
the relationship at first but now now
ten years later is how they find out by
seeing it at someone tell them I don't
know they don't have Google someone hurt
Japan had googled before we do that
China okay
very racist right a really different
culture sorry yeah you know how dennis
is who's this bumper sticker says
they're all this
to me I didn't do any mr. Miyagi jokes
Miyagi that's why I do it because people
of Asia so yeah I mean it goes like
Japanese Korean Chinese other has
anybody in your life gotten mad at you
like or not like because the porns one
thing and people get past that
eventually I'm assuming but now that
you're doing the podcast where you're
kind of like talking about everything
that happens like that's this whole
other revealing part where it is right
yeah for sure
like I think my husband is way less
happy about the podcasting than the porn
why because now you're talking about I
can't stop talking about him and like
things that I'm not supposed to say like
I talked about his hemorrhoid 100 know
he had one yeah and like that was just
revealing too much and then along with
the ROI talk about fights I have with
him and it's it's hard not you know you
know like when you're talking for hours
every day it's hard not to talk about
everything like it just comes up how
long is your podcast so on KFC radio we
do it twice a week one hour a day okay
and that's not the only podcast you're
doing yes okay so you got two hours a
week and yeah he has like you talking
about his certain things I mean he
doesn't like he doesn't even listen I've
requested that he doesn't listen to it
because then I feel like I can't talk
about everything and I want to talk
about every sure you sure yeah is there
anything you don't want him talking
about though like if he was doing a
podcast or I think like look that's a
little off-limits I can't I can't think
of anything no you're pretty young bit
more open I mean I guess he wouldn't I
wouldn't want him to like talk [ __ ]
about my parents no no no do they like
him they love him oh they do yeah and he
likes them he likes them I mean I think
they like him a little bit more than he
likes them why my parents are like
obsessed with him they just they just
like really love him he's such a good
guy
like he's like he wouldn't you meet him
you just know he's a good person
so now what is your podcast about what
do you guys come in if he's in the
middle of a DP scene
that really that's an amazing way to
meet somebody
yeah it's true he has a good vibe um so
my podcast is with Kevin Clancy and John
vital Berg and it's just kind of I don't
know we're kind of like a misfit of
three people which I always think is the
best group of people we're all there in
very different places in our lives you
know I'm a married porn star Kevin's
married with a kid John is single like
very single and yeah we just like kind
of cover everything from like current
events to just life's commentating on
everything yeah life's tough yeah it's
been a lot a lot a lot of fun it's a
popular podcast - then / - I I was at
the barstool office a couple weeks ago -
dude cat Thames podcast and it really is
a fun place though the whole like office
looks like the apartment that Tom Hanks
gets in big you know it's like all bits
like hardwood and it's wide open their
windows everywhere yeah and it's very
like it's it's such a crazy environment
like every day it's like you know it's
kind of like remember Owen Wilson in
Zoolander
yeah yeah like that like there's just
like crazy [ __ ] happening every day
there was a kangaroo in the office the
other day for no reason at all it's yeah
so it's funny because when I call it my
real job people are like that is not a
real job so he had on um well so we just
started he did yeah we um we had Buzz
McAllister from home alone on and he's
been our first guest so far and that was
last week Oh Devon refresh territory
yeah I know Devon he's a good guy
yeah so that that's you know I I got the
last line in that movie you know
did he really yeah Kevin what did you do
to my room I'll hit the credit ya up
number one number one yeah I could have
used that information last week but I
don't know I I think I feel like our
show is the best one we don't have
guests it's funny I say this as a guest
on your show but um I don't know like I
like I like just like talking to the
same people all the time yeah I enjoy
that too sometimes we get [ __ ] if our
guests aren't great we have some great
ones so you're obviously a good guest
cuz you talk like you know and your help
Arius on twitter your twitter is
genuinely [ __ ] funny I should read
your book I didn't read your book but I
should have I should have brought you
one I wish I had I didn't ask
hey what about your candles I'm
fascinating of canvas so I started a
candle line and it it's totally a joke
that went way too far my friend started
a candle line and he sent me a bunch to
like just promo on social media and then
I and I have 86 candles on display in my
house I'm like a candle not each and I
was like oh really I love them so I was
like I'm gonna start making my own
candles and stop buying so many candles
and spending so much money so I started
making my own candles and then I was
like oh my god I'm gonna sell candles
and then I was like I'm just gonna sell
100 and then a hundred turned into a
thousand a thousand turned into 5000 and
now my house is just taken over by
candle supplies going shark and well
except the candles have names like daddy
issues and like they smell like that
body spray and cigarettes where that one
smells like drugstore perfume and cash
and like it's it's been a lot of fun but
at this point I'm like what have I
gotten myself into I have 4700 more
candles to sell you make them boring
them one by one on my own
yeah where did I do this at my house in
California when I'm in California you
live in LA yeah I want to see your
candle okay come over I literally had a
girl what I might offer to make me she
had a candle I'm like wow that's really
nice and she'd made it I'm like it
smells amazing and shake oh yeah I got
the wax and I did it with the UH with
like jasmine or whatever it was [ __ ]
awesome teach you how to make candle I'm
such a queen that's what I want to learn
it I want to go to a porn stars hasn't
learned candle making and you know I
really am the source of poeple to make
it bright
where were you going down are you
standing out you're leaving what's about
to go to bathroom sweetie would you have
to make a wonder after I feel like
Forrest Gump
have to go to the bathroom - it is No
yeah hey I've been drained a lot of
water this morning okay we should do a
braised tender 15
you came in a half-hour early so we know
our time with you - my plan so what
won't you'll hang with us the rest of
the show and on account of they was free
I must have drank me about 15 dr. Danny
had a bunch of dr. peppers so as in here
when we get back by the way we should
number one try to figure out what number
one cry yes and number two have you seen
Dennis Falcone's boots no is that what
you're trying to there like child
they're nice am their children's biker
but let me just show me they're not yes
I can't really are some children's
they're very small they're very cm
little titties that look like the shoes
that were on my Shazam doll when I was a
kid those are kids yeah that looks like
you ever watched sons of anarchy that's
like the little boots that Jax tellers
kids were wearing in the crib what
you're Italian right yes
Italian men have small feet but big
dicks dance let's see Wow I do have
smoke do you won't talk about it dick I
have to go to the bathroom
Oh Danny used to make okay listen I'm
gonna follow Dennis to the bathroom and
get a look at that guy no no Pete I'll
report it's a secure a si Aki RA calm
and the podcast it's KFC radio when can
they hear it and where hi you can find
it on Tuesdays and Thursdays on iTunes
or you can also go to barstoolsports.com
and if you want to see me New Year's Eve
coming to the Tarrytown Music Hall it's
my last gig of the tour and Sam anything
you want to promote besides you're
amazing premiere on oh yeah if you
missed the if you're interested in
seeing what we did on the pre-show last
night it's on WWE's YouTube channel if
you look up roadblock end of the line
kickoff show you can watch the whole
thing for free there and sadly Travis is
leaving the show all right we'll be
right back
now which one is a Sakura that one all
right big boy
oh Jenny yes hold on Big Boy turn to my
daddy did you make urinated attaboy
nobody sinks Anakin's somebody just
posted a video of me and they were doing
like a new day on wrestling does like
this clap like this rhythmic clap
that was very on with me and they were
do unwritten ik isn't even a word as it
is they were doing uh they were doing it
on the show last night and I started
like dancing to it you know being goofy
and somebody just put up a video that
said Sam Roberts didn't forget that he
danced oh very good
don't let me forget that I danced it's
very important yeah I think that's right
and there's a bunch of versions of it I
said don't let him forget that she
danced why you can go to so many
versions
don't let them forget that you danced so
Danny we we got way off topic but when
was the last time like what what it'll
tear you up a little bit yeah I I think
I did cry at Rudy to the football game
you like that kind of teared up when
they carry Rudy around it what anybody
what is he [ __ ] break runs one [ __ ]
plane yeah the score yeah Rudy cried
since like 19 like 87 that let me say
when tennis did Rudy hit a little close
to home would you who'd you sympathize
we had a figure with the jock in Rocky
too when she goes just win when Rocky's
you know Adrienne's coming out of the
coma or something really that
counterbalancing the pounding erection
you have when she fell on the feedbag
[Laughter]
life at some point yeah why'd any I
don't know I don't know I mean it's just
a movie I mean you know I felt bad when
Henry Hill went to jail why because it
was such a good committed a crime he
ratted you crying Shawshank
no no not even no raping him yeah you're
tough no no no he's a tough cookie tough
cookie ya know Brooks hung himself
what's real tight if need to yeah no no
no what then he's the type of guy who
laughs at a Funeral
yeah sure does yeah especially if it's a
three-legged dog yeah I think I cried
probably once when I got fired you know
yeah because you wake up at night you go
damn I'm not getting paid to do that
cheers were flowing yeah you get a
little choked up yeah and you know what
there's and you know I think sometimes
not not crying over the big stuff masks
the pain of everyday life a little bit
for some of us you know and it mean have
better everyday pain are we really still
in this rut feeling like that doesn't if
you've if you've just shut off
emotionally from the big stuff maybe you
can you could push that away to know
you're in a rut though right no of
course not yeah I'm here on a popular
morning show I enjoy what I do you do I
do
sure i DJ parties I'm on the radio I
hang out with nice guys like you nice
wedding you went to and turned on hit on
yeah well yeah yeah Danny Danny was the
DJ of a gay wedding which is great
same-sex it's not the way Danny said
during the break he said yeah they were
there as there was two men they might
put a call for Danny but no I guess you
could call it that it's just you know
somebody a boy I guess a guy told me you
guys you're gonna do a gay wedding I
said all right fine
call it a same-sex mistake the wedding
was your wedding romantic as that was
yours oh no both marriages I got married
in Vegas did you want what's a
drive-through whoo and the other one was
an Elvis wedding I know on a whim or you
just you wanted to go there get married
he liked [ __ ] it we're here let's do it
was on a whim and the second one was
planned really for like a week do you
regret not doing like a big ceremony no
I would never want to do a big wedding
well you still got seven embarrassing
seven to go you like Vegas I mean it's
not even that I love Vegas it's just
like I don't even like like when it's my
birthday I don't even tell anyone cuz
I'm I get so embarrassed by that kind of
attention
yeah like so having a whole day
dedicated to me for a wedding is like
mortifying do you know I I get that too
we were I went out last night to dinner
with a young lady friend
I don't kissing today usually not one to
kiss and tell but today is a different
story and we were in this restaurant and
they were singing happy birthday to this
woman and I said it's amazing like it
that's so mortifying like I can tell
jokes to a thousand people but if eight
people sing happy birthday I want to
commit suicide it's humiliating yeah
absolutely and it's the same thing with
weddings it's like we're celebrating you
for just doing things that people do
like birthday is like were you still
alive so let's all sing people you know
and it's like what do you wear do you
look like what kind of face do you do do
you like you get embarrassed though the
other people in the restaurant hearing
them saying happy birthday it's like
makes you want to crawl up into myself
and die but yeah you can do it's a weird
what doesn't like you can you can have
anal sex on film and you're very
comfortable yeah you don't get nervous
that no not at all like I love it to me
like being filmed as part of a fantasy
like that that's the fetish for me have
you had guys not be able to get
erections on porn sure yeah all the time
and what do you makes you feel better
right well yeah because it's for them no
I mean everybody has a bad day but what
do take it personally or no no not at
all no how do they feel um I I mean I I
think the best cause you had a band I
think like whenever a guy fails the
scene like can't get hard or can't come
or whatever I think that shows so much
character like how he deals with that
situation cuz there's definitely the
guys that like we kind of lash out it I
lash out at everything and like um
they'll blame the girl or the director
oh no or the environment or the spurn
ature is too hard or too soft or
whatever but like I think the guy that
can be like hey sorry guys I'm just
having a bad day like that's the best
kind of person so what do you do have
you had guys blame you
personally no because I'm nice but yeah
like there's definitely girls when you
get to set and you can tell they just
like would rather be somewhere else or
they're there for just for the money or
something and yeah like I'm sure that
doesn't help the guy get hard but it's
also like not her job to get him hard
you know so when he blames her it's kind
of like well that's not her job so these
guys just have to block out that
and-and-and just like get blah
hardness is a tough job for guys like
you're not you're not always gonna be
able to [ __ ] who you wanna [ __ ] like
it's most of the time it's gonna be a
girl that you're not into tough job but
somebody's got to do it am i right daddy
oh yeah oh yeah
gotta get up every morning go to work
pay the bills but to be able to get your
dick hard in front of people for that's
fascinating how do you do it I couldn't
do it my dick would be like a [ __ ]
the sub comedian the best description of
a soft dick some comics and my dick was
like a stack of Dimes like what a great
way to describe an awful song I wish I
could credit who ever said that but
that's how my [ __ ] with me all the time
cuz you got a lot of them get off on it
they're artists so that's part of it for
a lot of them I mean I don't know if I
know but maybe like I've heard me so
excited the first time because I've been
in a relationship for 11 or 12 years
however long it's been that it wouldn't
be that difficult but if it started
happening regularly in front of people
yeah I don't know maybe not maybe not
but I feel like you'd be so exciting the
first time I could pull it off I will
say this I did this reality show where
called the sex factor where we just took
like 12 normal people and there's
another reality show with a very similar
name yeah so we shot six guys and six
girls who had never ever done porn
before but they were looking to break in
mm-hmm and we lived in a house for a
while and the guys like not a single one
could get hard in the beginning and like
these were like horny sexual young dude
wanted to do porn and it's like it was
funny at first but after a while it was
like all right we really need to see a
hard dick here because we are making
porn I don't have a show right now right
no you do have a show it's actually more
interesting if they can't get hard it's
off their house that's how we felt in
the beginning but like after so long
it's like okay like we've seen enough
softex like it's the joke is done so
would you bring a professional and that
would have been great if you really want
to wreck the guy you're bringing like a
man well Ferrara just a [ __ ] until she
cries
eventually you know some of them got
comfortable some of them never did but
like it just goes to show you like it
doesn't matter how horny you are or how
much you want it like it's it's not an
easy job to get your dick hard in front
of people I can't I can't get over I've
watched him shoot it a couple of times
and not that the women aren't impressive
but the men impressed me more just
because you have to get hard
it's--we yeah the dudes are way more
impressive and the fact that they can do
it in front and it's not a sexy
environment you think it's gonna be hot
but there's a drug-dealer all right more
more let's go all right turn over it's
like you guys marking out [ __ ]
directions yeah it's not hot not to
mention like what I call a director no
no I'm not disagreeing Jenni raised a
good point but that's why the guys
called the director directing the action
yes but it's still hard cuz you could
you keep a hard-on in front of people
sure no I've never done that I don't
know thank you very much that's really
nice to hear yes it really is and it's
really inaccurate I I appreciate her
vote of confidence but it's a very very
misguided vote I'd be an abomination I'm
bad one-on-one in front of people I'd be
humiliatingly terrible especially
because you think about it a lot like I
feel like every time this topic comes up
you bring up the fact that your dick
doesn't work half the time yeah so like
that's an insecurity that you already
have there's no way you're like putting
out the word and setting the bar really
low so you do meet people in real life
you're like a superstar
no they know they know it's like I'm
just so jaded and weird
he's become a jaded weirdo don't you
like this is it easy for you to get
turned on in real life - yeah I mean I'm
I'm I I can find something in anything
that'll turn me on you know it really
rare that I meet someone that I'm like
oh I could never have sex with them when
you were doing strap-on gives a lot of
hope to a lot of people I think every
man has a way to create a fanbase if you
look at any ten he's not a bad-looking
guy's an older guy what would you would
you fantasize with Denia to look at him
and go like wow you've spoken to him a
little bit you get very like it's I
don't I would use this to you like
whatever you're into but like what do
you think like think about it like
looking at Danny sizing him up like what
do you think would be fun about it he's
traditional he's only been with one
woman he's a you know gentleman maybe
he'd leave his boots I think he'd be a
very pass
love her you do yeah are you a
passionate lover Dennis I'd like to
think so yeah I think so yeah
do you enjoy anal sex no have you ever
done it no okay would you do with
someone who don't like an American cuz
they're homophobic they tend to be very
like more like macho right yeah
the mentality is more interesting not a
backdoor man so have you ever when you
were doing strap-on play did you ever
have a little mess on the strap-on yeah
you did right I mean I've been [ __ ] on
so many times in my life really welcome
to radio so you have you've had guys
[ __ ] on you during with strapped for
somebody but those rules are like you
very few rules in life but one is you're
not supposed to lick guys [ __ ] and
two is that when you are dominatrix
there would be no [ __ ] play you still
have not avoided being shat upon no yeah
really yeah
that should've been a no it was some of
the lyrics and that Alanis Morissette
song about irony being [ __ ] on when you
have a rule that's actually like so
profound yeah I think so like no matter
what you're gonna get [ __ ] on do you
remember the first time it happened yes
you do right and I I don't know I think
I'm a pretty like empathetic person so I
I wasn't like a Oh gross like I just
acted like well you it happened like
slowly or just an explosion
it wasn't an explosion like it wasn't
explosive if you know what I mean but
like it was I looked down and it was
there and you smelled it I smelled it
something mal
the smell is it's the smell more than
anything what you say anything cuz I
mean he was a ninja like yeah he wasn't
specifically into like Scott play or
anything like that you didn't tell me go
clean up it was me it the first time it
was me and three other girls two or
three other girls so I just like excused
myself and then like your poo pees on
the floor
yeah excuse me mister and you put the
thing in his face could you clean this
with your mouth was he embarrassed I I
don't even know that he knew it happened
you dropped a falcone sir saying there
you
[ __ ] yeah only took a half hour oh right
like that's your only option
what could possibly act natural like
there is no natural response to act
natural to being [ __ ] upon us to go by
any means don't act natural okay yeah
that's because I mean you know I think
it sucks to be [ __ ] on but it sucks more
to [ __ ] on someone what that's a very
sane attitude really are a nice person
like you're a great person
that's that should be the rule like what
worse what's worse being [ __ ] upon or
accidentally [ __ ] on something I
agree with her but I'm a creep yeah I
agree with her on that one but I'm a
total look I would take I would say yeah
having feces on me would be worse than
anything Danny what do you think you're
gonna have that when you change those
diapers my friend that's true yeah baby
you think it's still gross talking about
that it's a baby we're talking about
feces I know but you're talking about
scant play with babies now no no he's
got really weird Adrienne - Michael your
this mic is mics not on which ones you
my gosh it's eight just telling fun
eight ok comment Adrian yeah we were
talking about [ __ ] on getting a new dick
no no [ __ ] on a strap-on yeah she said
somebody dropped it on the floor because
you're gonna get it when you change
diapers listen do that you're not gonna
change diapers gonna do what you were
talking about that's not part of the
process yeah you don't clean diapers
with your penis
why is no judging yeah Paul and his
friend Dennis sure you know you clean it
out you distract them you read me wrong
okay but it's just I think you might
have misspoken No
okay so you the first time you did you
just kept going that that to me would be
humiliating for the guy yeah that's what
I mean like I don't want to humiliate
him in a bad way I only want to
humiliate anyone the way they want to be
humanely give or spit on someone
yeah that's pretty common right yeah
that's pretty odd thing too I kind of
like that I like it you do yeah yeah
being spit on spitting on someone is
kind of fun yeah yeah the worst if
someone has like dry spittle oh there's
none of it yeah it's just like [ __ ]
four drops like we do there's somebody
spits on you and they have bad breath
yeah that would suck happens yeah it's
happened but like I feel like once I'm
getting [ __ ] I don't like notice
things like that oh really
yeah like all that stuff goes away all
that stuff goes away yeah like I could
sit here and be like I don't do this I
don't do that but like once I'm [ __ ]
I feel in the throes of passion yeah you
could ignore a lot yeah you lose
yourself in it yeah definitely
yeah it's hard for me to do that I keep
getting wrapped up in like the room in
the moment yeah I couldn't I can't know
it but I can't get into it
I can't just be free I told you I was
[ __ ] a girl for one I make it as I
saw those [ __ ] I was [ __ ] my girl
was like her eyes were closed on how do
you in like how do you just zone out I
can't do it wait do you close your eyes
or do you keep them open no I just look
around I don't want to look really I'm
terrible I mean I'm a fan of keeping my
eyes open but not like because I'm
looking around yeah like I don't know
what to look at like she was like her
eyes are closed she was just enjoying I
need so much bells and whistles I was
like what I don't know how you enjoy
this Jess doesn't like it I leave my
eyes open well she has to close her eyes
even when we're kissing I never do that
yeah I never do that and it's like
you're like labeled a creep when you
happen but I don't respect that you know
what we should start a movement right
well it's open because with your eyes oh
but do you kiss with your head tilted to
the side or do you face each other
straight on I mean I guess it depends I
don't know I yeah I guess you have to
tilt a little bit otherwise your nose is
would doing a practice kissing
what do you practice kissing with a
friend
you're asking questions of like an
eleven-year-old are you supposed to tilt
your head no I'm asking just wait with
your friends what's frenching no no I'm
asking because I know how I kiss I
always turn my head and my eyes are
closed I actually do that like a foot
before I go in I turn eyes closed then
just lunge right but I always know but I
I to me it's weird to keep your eyes
open you got to tell your head a little
bit otherwise your notices would some
people don't know I've kissed people who
just kissed straight on them it's a
really weird situation you're kissing to
get it right like you take like to learn
the other person's mouth and what they
like it's not always not if you know
what you're doing that's not true that's
subjective you are not a great kisser
I've actually been told I am just kiss a
few dozen times before it's like real
like you have to everyone's different
you know that's not true
it might be a combination it just tries
weird [ __ ] I stick my tongue out and I
wait for their mouth to open I put my
tongue in and I go back and forth across
their teeth I have to scrape the bottom
teeth to lead to upper teeth and I pull
my tongue hold on straight on I hold it
their face you French tennis night I'm a
French tennis no but I'm saying when you
kiss a person everyone has like I don't
like people who are too aggressive with
their tongue I don't like people who
don't use their tongue I kissed a girl
one time what a short tongue it was
[ __ ] awful but I mean like there's a
little thing that every person's mouth
is a little bit different every person
opens their mouth a little differently
every person uses their tongue a little
bit differently and that's not that's
learned that's not automatic like a
[ __ ]
every girl sucks you dick a little
differently every woman wants to [ __ ]
yes yes everyone wants to [ __ ] eaten a
little differently yeah so why is she
kissing being different like if you
think you know how do you post it like
okay
she likes her [ __ ] lick rapidly and
harsh then go in the next girls like
but that's why sex with girls is so fun
because like we're so picky and so
different and such a challenge whereas
guys it's like I feel like I opened my
mouth and you come yeah that's a great
motto in life that's how I feel as a
comedian it's like an orgasm of laughs
yeah an eargasm it's right in your gasm
so you know I've been I think
everybody's a little different I learned
and some people suck at kissing I hate
to see a terrible kiss you know what I
think you're right actually there's
something to be said about that like I
think a good kisser is someone who can
adapt to any person's style and kind of
like be sensitive enough that you're not
opening your mouth too much for someone
who doesn't like their mouth open too
much yeah you would you know just a
little bit you pay attention right you
pay attention but let's learn and it
takes a couple of times once in a while
or no bro no I'll sit down afterwards I
have a little notebook and I'll check
mouth opening a distance we measure I do
measurements I take the I'm certain to
take measure
kissing statistic and I'll put a lines a
red line open ya mouth too wide too much
saliva making too much noise you may not
have great chemistry with most of the
people that you're with Jim well again a
lot of times it's a lot of times it's a
one-and-done you might be correct yeah
yeah that's probably why no I enjoy kiss
that's very important I love it you know
yeah I love a good smoocher and also go
to our hope you smooch proper but again
what is good because they come over and
grab a smooch I've kissed women who
sucked at it who [ __ ] sucked at it
and I'm like maybe other guys think
they're amazing I can't I don't miss her
one man's trash is another exactly I
guess so but I don't think so there
people are bad kisses are good kissers
there's nothing but that's very
subjective yeah I think that's a really
close much it really is safe now all of
a sudden she's on Team Jim first she was
on Team Sam now she thinks you're a
piece of [ __ ] good yeah hurtful that is
we should be sitting perched on a
strap-on why but he holds her nose by
the way David sure never gave me a piece
of art I like David a lot he did it my I
did the the Potter cast and I did was so
much fun lot of kissed and he's posting
a little piece of art they never got
mine doesn't he get them the people
after they do it just a lie just my
manager my manager told me like you
enjoy a little something I don't want
anything worth money he's just gonna
draw something he didn't like I wouldn't
sell it everything he draws his work
money I'm talking about wouldn't sell it
I mean yeah yeah you know Shepard
Fairey's give me a couple of nice things
that he signed yeah Sabbath um I gotta
sell that I'm sure he would give you one
yeah what are you looking at so does him
you guys here Henry Heimlich is dead oh
I'm Lake that guy was alive I Danny just
wrote that down
no he just hand me the whole news story
about a show prep we didn't get through
that sounds like someone that would have
been alive in like 1920
he was 96 yeah by the way do you know
who his nephew was or his grandson Anson
Williams from Happy Days Potsie Weber
really that was he was related it might
be an uncle he was related to Henry
Heimlich and he had something to do with
making the Heimlich maneuver popular I
remember what it was he told it on our
show he also went out with Lyndon
Johnson's daughter what whoa he didn't
[ __ ] a kid what uh like what a royal
yeah what do you guys hear this the
Heimlich maneuver is a series of five
abdominal thrusts designed to dislodge
an object blocking the airwaves even at
the age of 92 only four years ago
Heimlich battled the American Red Cross
which recommends that 5 back slaps
should come before abdominal thrusts so
make sure that they're not what like
just I don't know why would you battle
about a guy choked to death no gotta be
you gotta be a man who was a [ __ ] weird
death he had a stroke while being [ __ ]
in the ass
that would be great right
when ironic waiters I was people and
you'd die in such a silly fashion never
see mr. hands buries the horse dick in
the new guy guy died it's real guy died
of a perforated :
they must Kenneth pinion Boeing engineer
since you mentioned that yeah he died
getting [ __ ] me as my horse it's a
rough way to go in I don't know cartoon
it's from Godfather Godfather
okay so Heimlich died yeah unfortunately
passed away yeah 95 96 he had a heart
attack people in their nineties so
that's the three right Alan Thicke last
week no not for Heimlich no counting 90
year olds died they should have been
dead years ago like okay fine but that's
enough clothes for a just attitude to
have is it there's no need good job
Gabor is Paris Hilton's grandma have
some she was married to Chiron open
that's right but is in the gram grandma
I'm gonna guess step oh okay she's
married nine times she no I don't think
that's him that's a blood thing that's
more of a you know step yeah I don't
think anybody remembers she was married
to [ __ ] you the one that said don't get
mad get even right or is that Ivanka I
don't know that's probably one of them
she also would say funny sharing the
Tonight Show
like she would say I just want a man
who's compassionate and understanding is
that too much to ask him a millionaire
you know like she was just like one of
those like famous from doing nothing but
being famous and then she was like hey
where's the [ __ ] is my life don't get
mad get even
oh right yeah he said that right I think
he said that in the kitchen of the
[ __ ] Ambassador Hotel where I at a
time
yes we are it was really fun having you
on thank you for having me I had a lot
of you should come back when you're new
if you're in New York Elisha share all
the time yeah we don't have you back a
lot many was a fine having you in for
the first hour as well thank you very
much for saying you didn't do great this
is a third hour no I just meant it ii a
third hour you were here so he was
unnecessary but we were happy to have
him oh I see
thank you
he said your job is like a great
accessory and I think by the way a
homerun for Jim Norton sitting in this
seat for the first time in his radio
career yeah I mean come on you did great
happy birthday
shall we no what you saying are you
trying out for this position permanently
or no we but Sam always does it and it's
like I yeah he was away this morning he
could have been anything feel like
coming in and gonna fly back from
Pittsburgh I don't mind doing it it's
fine but it's like I didn't know what to
say yeah this morning yeah yeah I was
comfortable doing we're gonna switch off
on an off call and you're comfortable in
that so you better not see it doesn't
matter yeah this is easy
you look good there I'm comfortable here
yeah are you comfortable your desk
Thanks he's sitting on a dildo by the
way and asked if they can hear your
podcast how you search can't see radio
on iTunes you can also search for it on
barstoolsports.com and if you want to
see me in porn please go to wicked
pictures calm yeah lots of great options
tremendous porn star one of the biggest
and really what you want best anal scene
right in my correct view yeah I wouldn't
and I want performer of the year and mm
and that's a big thing for ABN yeah yeah
it's yeah I was happy good for you
and yeah Dennis I'm not 70 Channel yes
somebody's on seven Dennis the Menace
and uh and Sam you already know Sam just
put support that duh that wrestling
everybody's been cool about the pre-show
what's it called the the road gig show
pre-show what I remember road block end
of the line kickoff show yes
checkouts and they get they get the
YouTube views up and they'll use them
again and see me in New Year's Eve in
Tarrytown we're here tomorrow we only
have two more shows and then we're fired
so uh Travis I'm gonna miss you
[Music]